[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le
[Musique]
l'hypothèse de rendre obligatoire le
vaccin pose problème ce qui est en cause
c'est votre liberté
mais ce qui est en cause aussi c'est la
liberté des autres
et entre la liberté individuelle et la
liberté collective il faut choisir la la
la gouvernance est compliqué la pandémie
après les gilets jaunes le terrorisme
islamique ça fait quand même beaucoup
tout ça le fondement de la politique
c'est la rumeur ont réagi à des rumeurs
et plus qu'à des réalités ça comme
conséquence que la politique est devenue
un métier du spectacle
la loi est un objet de communication
politique trop de lois tuent la loi et
les lois inutiles culé vol nwa
[Musique]
elle a uni département si passé ce
dimanche sous couvre-feu avancé à 18
heures une mesure contestée mais jugé
nécessaires pour tenter d'éviter la
course folle de l'épidémie d'e.coli de
19 sur le territoire où le nouveau
variant britannique inquiète c'est le
cas à marseille on a détecté un cluster
familiale nous ferons un point là dedans
un instant ailleurs en europe l'épidémie
que 8,19 s'accélère l'allemagne compte
désormais 40 mille morts la chancelière
angela merkel prévient que le pire reste
à venir dans la tente des effets de la
vaccination
au royaume uni le nouveau variant
provoque une flambée des cas le pays qui
l'a identifié en premier confiné est les
mesures de restriction provoque encore
de la colère c'était le cas aujourd'hui
en république tchèque
et puis quatre jours après l'assaut du
capitole par des pros trump la situation
reste tendue aux etats unis une
vingtaine de militants black light
bateau avons fait face à la nuit
dernière à près de 2000 soutien du
président américain sur une plage proche
de los angeles
à dix jours de la fin de son mandat une
nouvelle procédure de destitution plane
sur donald trump
[Musique]
bonsoir à tous bienvenue si vous nous
rejoignez sur rt france le couvre-feu
avancé à 18 heures a débuté dans huit
départements supplémentaires 15 sont
déjà concernés par la mesure destinée à
ralentir la propagation du virus parmi
les territoires concernés citons par
exemple les bouches du rhône le vaucluse
et la côte d'or
de nouvelles restrictions loin de faire
l'unanimité notamment chez les élus
locaux écouter les sénateurs et l'ère
alain houpert 18 heures c'est au de dire
que les gens souvent à l'aise je parle
au passé à l'est dans les commerces
après leur travail ils ne pourront que
le faire donc ils vont s'entasser le
samedi et le dimanche matin donc avec
des problèmes de contamination je pense
que c'est une décision au doigt mouillé
une décision qui n'est pas du tout
responsable ce sont les chants qui
fondent la nation
ce ne sont assez pas d'état ni les
discours qui se veulent fédérateur ce
sont les gens ce sont des français qui
font naître
il va falloir avoir son attestation ne
sommes comme le seul pays à exiger
d'avoir des autos attestations et on a
vu que le conseil d'état revenait sur
les 3 et 3 millions d'âmes en il va
falloir réviser ses 3 millions d'amendé
peut-être les rembourser jeu on est dans
une aporie politique une aporie
complètement technocratique
s'ils sont contestés ces couvre feu a
lancé vise à enrayer le risque de
propagation du virus surtout que le
nouveau variant a été détecté à à
marseille il s'agit d'un cluster
familiale au départ est le maire de la
cité phocéenne évoque une situation
virale inquiétante et demande au
gouvernement de renforcer les tests dans
les aéroports d'ailleurs il a mis en
place une stratégie inédite
dans sa vie l'écouté évidemment qu'on
est inquiet c'est pour ça qu'on a réagi
tout de suite il ya aucune ville en
france capable de pouvoir déployer sur
son territoire un bataillon aussi
efficace que le bataillon des marins
pompiers dès qu'on a suivi hier après
midi quand le ministre de la santé puis
ensuite le préfet nous a prévenus de la
souche anglaise du virus mutant à
marseille nous avons déployé nos marins
pompiers pour aller tester au plus près
des personnes dont les noms nous ont été
fournies par la grèce dans les tests et
les surfaces pour aller tester les
habitations et pour aller tester les
personnes pour faire quoi pour tenter de
circonscrire ce virus pour tenter
d'isoler ces personnes pour tenter n'est
pas de propagation du virus
pour l'instant il y a on le sait sur la
quarantaine de personnes qui ont été
identifiées vingt-trois personnes qui
sont positives au moment où je vous
parle nous ne savons pas si c'est le
mutant si c'est le virus mutant cessé de
virus mutant voilà c'est le virus mutant
dont on est sûr sept d'entre elles sept
sont huit ans virus mutant c'est le
virus anglais pour les autres on le sait
on le sait pas encore faut donc vous
l'avez compris les isoler il faut aller
chercher d'autres traces on l'a compris
il est très virulent qu'est ce que ça
veut dire ça veut dire qu' il peut y
avoir une deux trois cinq six personnes
qui ont échappé
bien évidemment au contrôle de l'état
qui ont peut-être pas pratiquer des
gestes barrières et qui sont allés
contaminer d'autres personnes
c'est pour ça qu'on a besoin de mettre
tous les moyens tous les moyens en
commun tous les moyens nécessaires pour
essayer de les identifier
nous ne voulons pas au moment où il ya
une recrudescence du virus au moment où
on voit dans les eaux usées le virus
qu'on monte à marseille que la souche
mutante prennent racine à marseille
c'est pour ça qu'on réagit extrêmement
rapidement oui et nous trouvons gérard
filoche membres de la gauche
démocratique et sociale et jean paul
stahl infectiologues au chu de grenoble
bonsoir à messieurs merci d'être avec
nous en direct soir tu es france on
vient d'entendre le maire de marseille
peut-être un commentaire là dessus jean
paul stahl est ce qu'à votre avis ce
variant et il circule activement sur le
territoire
hoyé circulent dans quelles proportions
je ne peux pas vous le dire mais y
circulent je voudrais d'abord rectifier
une rameaux qui a été prononcée qui est
faux ce virus mutant n'est pas plus
virulent c'est à dire que quand ils
infectent quelqu'un et ne le rend pas
plus malade et cette personne n'a pas
plus de risques qu'une autre de faire un
séjour en réanimation par exemple donc
il faut remettre les choses à leur place
mais il est plus contagieux ça c'est
c'est vrai et donc à ce titre là il est
plus dangereux puisqu'il peut provoquer
plus d'infections est donc évidemment
plus de personnes atteintes d'une forme
grave et il n'est pas plus virulent
alors après l' esquive circulent ben oui
forcément y circulent en france sans
doute à ma bruit dans une proportion que
pour l'instant on peut pas chiffrer mais
ce variant circule ce qu'il ne change
pas grand chose à vrai dire parce que
effectivement peut être plus inquiet
d'accord mais en termes pratiques
qu'est-ce qu'il faut faire derrière va
appliquer les mesures barrières
il n'y a que ça et dans les endroits où
il y a une une incidence élevée de la
circulation virale et bien ma foi c'est
le couvre feu et à l'extrême ça sera le
confinement
alors justement ce couvre feu la huit
départements supplémentaires à ce soir à
partir de 18h donc pratique se couvre
ceux avancés gérard filoche pourtant les
élus locaux
voilà exprime quand même un certain
mécontentement pour pour quelles raisons
selon vous ben je la comprends il ya
beaucoup de jeunes à cause de toutes les
mesures de précaution de prévention qui
sont prises mais moi j'écoute monsieur
qui est infectiologues et je pense aussi
que le maire de marseille et le paris
attend marseillais réagit très bien faut
prendre les mesures de prévention qui
sont nécessaires au fur et à mesure la
prévention dans notre pays elle est
totalement insuffisante de façon
générale 1 c'est 5,4 pour cent des
dépenses de santé et la vaccination est
le même puisque à présent il ya eu peu
de moyens engagés et un retard
visiblement le gouvernement ait eu on
est toujours en retard d'une plage quand
il n'y avait pas de soi il n'y avait pas
de poussan n'y avait pas de gel il n'y
avait pas de tester paris et pas de
respirateur il n'y avait pas de blues il
n'y avait pas grand il n'y avait pas de
lunettes y avait pas de soignants et il
n'y avait pas assez de lits dans les
hôpitaux de façon générale et maintenant
il n'y avait pas assez de vaccins ont ça
ne va pas assez pour voir ce que la
vraie gérant sillage
pour revenir à ce couvre-feu est ce
qu'il est utile est-ce qu'il est utile
ce couvre-feu avancé à 18 heures je peux
pas juger moi je regarde les décisions
qui sont qui sont prises 6 et 18 heures
et 18 heures 19 heures peut-être faut-il
comme ça a été dit précédemment un
confinement général à nouveau nous
allons nous allons voir moi je ne suis
pas en mesure de décider nous ne
disposons pas de toutes les informations
en termes de développement du virus sur
le territoire ce virus mutant et donc je
suis très prudent j'écoutais je suis
respectueux je dis aux gens il faut
écouter la prévention c'est très
important
le principe de précaution et de
l'emporter ça mais j'ai été longtemps
inspecteurs du travail et on disait aux
gens porter des chaussures de sécurité
il n'y avait pas des accidents pour tous
les gens mais on est obligé tous les
gens à porter les chaussures de sécurité
c'était pareil pour les casques il n'y
avait pas forcément des dangers pour
tout le monde mais fallait des casques
dans des chantiers
et bien tout le monde aujourd'hui est un
peu comme
un chantier faut porter des chaussures
de sécurité aux portes et des casses au
sens où on fait des gestes barrières et
où on respecte les mesures de
confinement qui sont pris que j'en fasse
elle même les réfractaires ça c'est
personnel que les mesures de confinement
ont peut-être pas été suffisantes donc
derrière nous l'agent postal parmi les
réfractaires à ce couvre-feu avancé il
ya ceux qui argumentent en disant que à
18h finalement là les populations à
risque elles sont déjà chez elle selon
vous est ce que cette mesure elle peut
s'avérer efficace un problème c'est pas
l'épopée les personnes à risque le
problème c'est la circulation du virus y
compris chez ceux qui ne sont pas à
risque et je dirais même surtout chez
ceux qui ne sont pas à risque et donc
non c'est bien ça c'est un argument qui
n'est pas valable
là le virus y circule chez les personnes
à faible risque et qui contamine les
personnes à risque et à ce moment-là
froid et les formats quand on est bien
d'accord mais je le savais ce virus y
tombe pas du ciel il c'est un individu
porteur du virus qui le transmet un
individu récepteur bon à partir de là
toutes les mesures quelles qu'elles
soient toutes les mesures qui tendent à
diminuer ce contact entre le porter et
le récepteur est une bonne mesure
alors après le confinement à 20 heures
d'accord il a marché il a montré qu'il
était efficace parce qu'on a vus avant
le le confinement le couvre feu
pardon je me suis relax cus mais le
couvre-feu marche on a vu les résultats
juste au début du confinement il n'était
pas assez important ses résultats d'où
le confinement qui a suivi mais ça
marche
il ya un effet maintenant vous dire si
le 18 heures c'est mieux de 20 heures ou
16 heures mieux que 18 heures tout ce
qui empêche l'interaction entre
individus et est une bonne chose alors
on dire sur votre l'abscisse les
résultats on va rouvrir savoir
avant d'avoir c'est évidemment la magie
on va rebondir justement jean paul stahl
sur votre lapsus le confinement est ce
qu on peut hésiter
gérard filoche à votre avis un troisième
confinement parce que c'est ce que ce
soit justement éviter lé les autorités
pour pouvoir concilier la vie économique
et des impératifs sanitaires et je
comprends qu'il faille donner la
priorité à la santé et non pas si vous
me permettez au fric
ainsi tant pis y'a des choses qui marche
pas tant pis s'il ya des productions qui
ne se font pas c'est la santé en
priorité
donc le gouvernement quand il prend des
mesures de santé je le soutiens quand il
dit dans un an ça coûte trop cher je le
soutiens plus quand monsieur le maire
donne 100 milliards ou en entreprise au
lieu dé donner aux pauvres on a huit
millions de personnes aujourd'hui quand
des problèmes alimentaires en france on
a 10 millions de pauvres
évidemment tout ça a un coût et basse et
coûte que coûte il faut donner la
priorité à la santé
et ça veut dire aussi des choses
précises parce que on est en situation
de danger
eh bien il faut aider les soignants je
plaide à nouveau pour les salaires des
soignants 300 euros pour tous je plaide
à nouveau pour qu'il y ait des ailes à
tous ceux qui en bas souffrent des
conséquences du confinement
parce qu'on peut pas dire aux gens
protégez-vous ce qui est rien et en même
temps ne pas leur donner de quoi manger
puisque ils vont plus avoir à des unités
de travail
il faut que les les jeunes disposent de
l'équivalent d'un rsa parce que si où
ils peuvent pas de s'en sortir il faut
que les gens qui sont pauvres et d aide
suffisante et que celle ci ne soit pas
réservée au cac 40
monsieur le maire et monsieur macron
donne l'essentiel de l'argent qu'ils
dépensent aujourd'hui au cac 40
c'est une anomalie total faut le donner
aux gens qui souffrent des conséquences
du confinement et des exigences de
protection de santé et je pense que tout
ça se ce lien
de la même façon que la reconnaissance
du coup vite comme maladie
professionnelle parce que rial et
policiers il ya les soignants mais ya
plein de gens qui continuent de
travailler malgré ce que nous sommes en
train de dire et ils n'ont pas la
reconnaissance du coup vite comme
maladie professionnelle forêt se soit
fait de façon absolument systématique et
je pense que c'est une vision là sont
aussi importantes
les gens pour ceux qui travaillent c'est
aussi important pour subir les
conséquences du confinement c'est
désagréable confinement c'est
désagréable les gestes barrière c'est
désagréable et couvre feu mais il faut
quand même qu'on pense et ça en vain de
redistribution des richesses que nous
avons en direction de ceux qui en ont
besoin
j'ai un très grand reproche monsieur
macron à monsieur le maire c'est
d'utiliser ils ont trouvé l'argent
magique alors qu'ils aient qu'il n'avait
pas et ils l'utilisent pas dans la bonne
direction
ils le donnent en eau aux riches sur le
donnait en bas à tous ceux qui sont
pauvres qui souffrent de la situation
c'est vrai qu'on voit bien gentil ça les
conséquences des restrictions sanitaires
notamment monde n'a pas cité mais on
peut citer les les commerçants les
cafetiers et les restaurateurs
tous les professionnels aussi des
secteurs de la culture l'idc on voit
bien pour le gouvernement c'est
d'éditeurs confinement c'est le cas en
ce moment par exemple au royaume uni on
a reconfirmé surtout avec la circulation
du nouveau variant comment on peut
hésiter un jean paul stahl un troisième
confinant en france mais en arrêtant de
penser que c'est les autres qui doivent
faire les efforts c'est à dire que
chacun d'entre nous est responsable
c'est pas le gouvernement qui nous
contamine c'est pas une administration
sadique qui nous contamine c'est chacun
d'entre nous qui contamine ont d'autres
voisins quand on est porteur donc à
partir de là plutôt que de vitupérer
contre telle ou telle mesure
je pense qu'il ya un discours de
responsabilité à tenir en disant vous
êtes chacun d'entre vous responsables de
la contamination d'autres voisins donc
appliquer les mesures barrières
c'est extrêmement simple c'est à cette
condition là qu'on arrivera à éviter un
troisième confinement si on ne l'observé
pas si nos concitoyens ne l'observent
pas et on a vu qu'ils avaient quand même
une forte réticence à
l'observer à l'occasion des fêtes de fin
d'année eh bien ma foi
même si cette réticence est
compréhensible elle n'est pas
responsable et en tout cas elle est
responsable de quelque chose c'est du
troisième confinement s'il doit avoir
lieu on voit ce qui se passe ailleurs
chez nos voisins européens par exemple
en allemagne on l'a dit tout à l'heure à
l'angola merkel qui alerte face au pire
en attendant les effets de la
vaccination justement sur le front de la
campagne de vaccination libérant a
annoncé que ce week-end on devrait
passer la barre des 100000 vaccinées en
france à quoi s'attendre dans les
prochaines semaines à gérard filoche
j'explique ce sera pas 100 milles mais
des millions j'espère qu'il va enfin un
effort
au début ma chrome dadis et la guerre
mais il fait pas beaucoup d'efforts de
guerre pour la vaccination
parce que s'il y avait un effort de
guerre pour la vaccination serait déjà
plus avancées et donc je pète plutôt
dans ce sens là je plaide enfin pour que
ce que disait monsieur avant moi c'est
il faut faire c'est très fort et france
habilité mais en même temps faut
permettre une acceptabilité la
responsabilisation certain que ce soit
pas des sacrifices trop dur que ça ne
soit pas insupportable du point de vue
de ceux qui n'ont pas les moyens et
c'est là-dessus qu'il faut se tourner
parce que c'est lié de convaincre les
gens d'accepter des mesures de
protection et de prévention si en même
temps on leur donne les moyens de le
faire alors pour l'instant je partage
avec vous l'idée qu'il faut exiger au
sens responsabiliser mais je dis que
l'autre côté il n'ya pas la contrepartie
les contreparties financières tous les
moyens toutes les aides
ils vont en haut au gros et ou pas en
bas à ceux qui sont les plus frappés les
plus atteints par le virus ce sont les
ceux qui sont les plus démunis qui sont
les plus atteints aujourd'hui chaque
saison casse à ça qu'il faut adapter la
politique
après je me garderai bien je suis pas
infectiologues je suis je ne suis pas
compétent conduit à cesser 18h ou 19h
je me défends l'idée générale priorité à
la prévention et priorité à leurs
précautions et priorité à aider ceux qui
en souffrent et jean paul steijns est
confiant sur le front de la vaccination
en france pour les prochaines semaines à
la vaccination aura lieu le
le problème tout le monde est maintenant
à les vaccins les vaccins après avoir
dit le daxas je veux pas donc là il ya
déjà une forme de schizophrénie mais bon
peu importe tant mieux si on bascule du
côté de la réclamation du vaccin
ça c'est une chose très positive par
contre le vaccin alors lis tu sors pas
comme ça d'un claquement de doigts d'une
usine
lusine il faut la construire il faut la
produit il faut produire les vaccins en
quantité etc
vous imaginez qu'il y avait des besoins
actuellement dans le monde entier le
plusieurs milliards de doses
et ça il faut quand même les produits
donc effectivement la france a une une
quote-part dans toc la commande de
européenne mais c'est pas non plus des
quantités illimitées qui sont déversés
en france donc on est bien obligé
d'adopter une stratégie de priorisation
si on veut protéger les personnes pour
qui c'est vraiment utile dans un
contexte où il y à une relative rareté
du raft et du vaccin alors après un fil
du temps effectivement les quantités
vont augmenter ça c'est absolument
certain
d'autant plus que d'autres vaccins
sommes maintenant sur le point de sur le
point d'arriver il ya le pacs a modern à
la sellette cette semaine et puis elle
vaccin astra qui lui qui a des
conditions logistiques beaucoup plus
simple qui va arriver un tout petit peu
décalé et qui permettra d'augmenter la
masse des personnes que l'on pourra
vacciner mais ils y ont peut pas
s'attendre à vacciner dix millions
personnes comme ça alors on a 500 milles
12 cm absolument un faisable donc je
laisse des autres pays qui ont eu cette
stratégie d'utiliser très rapidement
tous les stocks disponibles et qui
maintenant se retrouve un petit peu la
bid
en attendant ce qu elles mêmes des
fournitures suivante
donc ils ont donné l'impression d'avoir
démarré la course très très fort mais
ils sont dans des phases de
ralentissement alors que nous on a
choisi une stratégie je dis pas qu'elle
est la meilleure
je ne m'avancerai pas je m'avancerai pas
là dessus et on dira lequel est la
meilleure quand tout sera fini
maintenant c'est beaucoup trop prématuré
au porter un jugement
simplement je prends une explication sur
le fait de ce dévoilement qui semble
mettre du temps mais en tenant compte de
la pesanteur administratif français ce
que tout le monde connaît c'est une
stratégie qui a été définie par des
vrais spécialistes de la vaccinologie et
et cheveux très sincèrement je la
soutiens merci beaucoup à vous gens
postent à l'infectiologue au chu de
grenoble merci également à vous gérard
filoche nombre de la gauche démocratique
et sociale en allemagne la situation est
également préoccupante le pays a franchi
ce dimanche la barre des quarante mille
morts liés au corps un navire uss
l'épidémie s'accélère et le pire reste à
venir selon angela merkel la chancelière
allemande qui redoute une saturation des
services hospitaliers ces prochaines
semaines pour le moment plus de 80 % des
lits dans les services de soins
intensifs du pays sont occupés le
royaume-uni a lui ares confiné pour
faire face à la propagation du nouveau
variant un nouveau variant identifié
pour la première fois outre manche
il n'est pas plus mortelle mais
hautement plus contagieux par ailleurs
le pays fait face à une flambée des cas
de contamination classique là bas on
recense plus de 3 millions de malades et
80 mille morts
les hôpitaux de londres sont au bord de
la saturation et la situation est très
préoccupante les précisions de quentin
au club devant l'envolée des nouveaux
cas de kovy 19
boris johnson re serre la vis si depuis
jeudi dernier
80% de la population sont de nouveau
soumis à un confinement strict le
premier ministre a décidé ce lundi soir
de réinstaurer un confinement pour toute
l'angleterre
will make your wedding avec la majorité
du pays déjà soumise à des mesures
extrêmes
il est clair que nous devons faire plus
ensemble pour maîtriser ce nouveau
variant pendant le déploiement de nos
vaccins
wavin xing awad cela signifie que le
gouvernement vous demande à nouveau de
rester chez vous
conséquence de ces nouvelles
restrictions les écoles resteront
fermées sur l'ensemble du territoire
il sera interdit de sortir sauf pour
aller faire ses courses
faire du sport ou si le travail en
présentiel et nécessaire oui nous devons
maintenant faire tout ce que nous
pouvons pour arrêter la propagation de
la maladie des écoles primaires les
écoles secondaires et les universités à
travers l'angleterre doivent passer des
services à distance à partir de demain
sauf pour les enfants vulnérables et les
enfants des travailleurs des secteurs
clés tout le monde sera toujours en
mesure d'accéder aux structures dédiées
à la petite enfance tels que les clashes
sanchez 9 à l'instar de l'angleterre le
pays de galles et d'irlande du nord ce
sont des jarres confiné respectivement
depuis les 20 et 26 décembre dernier en
écosse
la première ministre nicolas star jeunes
a également choisi de durcir les
dispositions en vigueur et a opté ce
lundi pour un nouveau confinement
nationale pendant l'intégralité du mois
de janvier pour que le vaccin gagne
cette course il est essentiel
d'accélérer la vaccination autant que
possible mais pour lui donner le temps
nécessaire pour prendre le dessus
nous devons également ralentir le virus
et comme il se propage plus rapidement
maintenant cela signifie que des
restrictions encore plus sévères sont
nécessaires nous constatons actuellement
une forte tendance à la hausse des
infections
en effet il n'est pas exagéré de dire
que je suis plus préoccupé par la
situation à laquelle nous sommes
confrontés aujourd'hui que je ne l'étais
à n'importe quel autre moment depuis
mars dernier la découverte du nouveau
variant du coc vite 19 il y a quelques
semaines a rendu la propagation du virus
incontrôlable dans l'ensemble du royaume
depuis sept jours le nombre de cas
recensés quotidiennement dépasse
systématiquement les 50000 personnes et
dans l'actualité en république tchèque à
elles étaient plus de 3000 dans les rues
de prague pour protester contre le
retour à des restrictions anti-corrida
léger début décembre le gouvernement
tchèque a remise en place à des mesures
plus strictes juste après les fêtes
comme la fermeture des bars et des
restaurants
le pays recense près de dix mille cas
quotidiens les étudiants en médecine
sont mobilisés pour soulager les
hôpitaux débordés sion quatre jours
après les incidents du capital des
centaines de supporters de donald trump
et des partisans du mouvement black
l'animateur se sont opposé pendant
plusieurs heures près d'une plage de san
diego en californie à la police c'est
l'adieu à contenir les assauts des deux
camps un policier a été légèrement
blessé par un jet de bouteille
aucune arrestation n'a été signalée et
dès demain donald trump pourrait se
retrouver sous le coup d'une nouvelle
procédure de destitution beaucoup le
jugent responsables de l'assaut du
capitole qui a fait cinq morts
même dans son propre camp sans
d'éloigner plusieurs de ses ministres
ont démissionné et son canal préféré de
communication du a été coupée twitter a
fermé définitivement son compte une
destitution numérique selon certains
experts
mais est ce vraiment légitime ou voit
cela avec kirill kotick of twitter
facebook et instagram snap chatwood
spotify youtube
bref tout donald trump est bloqué sur
tous les réseaux sociaux on y est
les gars femmes sont devenues tellement
puissante qu'elle peuvent désormais
techniquement empêcher n'importe qui de
s'exprimer ou tout simplement d'avoir
une existence sur la toile même le
président des états unis
alors évidemment il a fallu donner des
explications le pdg de facebook mark
zuckerberg a donc donné la sienne
les évènements choquants de ces
dernières 24 heures prouve que donald
trump entend user du temps qui lui reste
pour saper la transition pacifique des
pouvoirs avec joe biden nous pensons que
laisser le président utiliser nos
services durant la période de transition
représente un trop grand risque
le contexte a changé nos plateformes ont
été utilisée pour inciter à une
insurrection violente contre un
gouvernement démocratiquement élu
alors déjà prouve n'ont ils rien qui
prouve rien du tout l'invasion du
capitole par une meute de partisans de
trump était pour lui plutôt une épine
dans le pied qu'autre chose c'est pas
vraiment dans son intérêt twitter
explique quant à lui que le compte du
président est fermé jusqu'à nouvel ordre
parce que trump a posté auparavant à
tweet dans lequel il qualifiait les
assaillants de patriotes et donc cela
veut dire que quelque part il les
soutient et donc ça peut envenimer
davantage la situation et provoquer
d'autres incidents oui mais enfin on
n'en sait rien ce sont des suppositions
ni plus ni moins les grandes plateformes
de réseaux sociaux empêche littéralement
à président sortant de s'exprimer en se
basant sur des suppositions
si les tweets ne sont pas supprimés le
comte restera verrouiller les violations
futur eu des règles de twitter
entraîneront la suspension permanente du
comte de donald trump se croirait au
lycée quand on invoque la censure au nom
de la liberté c'est ya quand même un
problème quelque part chez nous en
france cette opération des réseaux
sociaux contre trump ont fait réagir la
classe politique évidemment stupéfiants
comment en sommes nous arrivés là que
les gaffes à décide seul hors de tout
contrôle de tout recours de qui peut
bénéficier du droit d'expression est
inquiétant la fermeture du compte de
donald trump par twitter si elle peut se
justifier par une forme de prophylaxie
d'urgence n'oppose pas moins des
questions fondamentales la régulation du
débat public par les principaux réseaux
sociaux au regard de leur seul cgu alors
qu'ils sont devenus de véritables
espaces publics et rassemble des
milliards de citoyens
cela semble pour le moins un peu court
d'un point de vue démocratique au delà
de la haine en ligne nous avons besoin
d'inventer une nouvelle forme de
supervision démocratique
on peut combattre trump et le chaos
qu'il a entraînés mais refusé de se
réjouir de voir les gaffes a décidé seul
sans contrôle du juge sans recours
possible quel président en exercice a le
droit d'avoir un compte ou non sur
twitter cela n'aide certainement pas la
démocratie
twitter suspens le compte de trump de
façon permanente dans l'ordre des
atteintes portées à la liberté
d'expression dans une démocratie c'est
la plus grave jamais commise
attention le bâillon de l'un peut
devenir la muselière de l'autre
battons-nous contre la censure
je déteste trump je déteste ses idées
mais qu'il ne puisse les exprimé sur
twitter ait qu'un chef de l'état encore
en activité se fasse en sueur et ça pose
un sujet effectivement ça pose un sujet
sommes-nous vraiment en train d'entrer
définitivement dans une ère où une
grande multinationale pourra décider de
la politique d'un pays
j'ai l'impression que les prochains mois
risquent d'être assez cocasse et c'est
la fin de ce journal merci à vous de
l'avoir suivi rond va se retrouver en
direct dans 30 minutes
restez avec nous sur arte france
[Musique]
le crime est tellement épouvantable que
je pense qu'une partie de l'église mais
comme une partie de la société ne veut
pas le voir de 1950 à aujourd'hui le
travail de la commission a permis
d'identifier trois mille victimes 1500
agresseurs ces chiffres sont forcément
très en deçà de la réalité puisque des
victimes sont décédées des victimes ne
peuvent pas parler peut-être ne
parleront jamais ça montre cette
tragédie qui lie à un système hôte